I've always been a huge fan of
MasterChef junior and today I get to be
a part of the show this is the set for
the pop-up restaurant group challenge
and what better settings than the beach
so down to the top six
so this is where we go up a level
explains young man don't try this right
we'll be quicker hatching a little
chicken let's go I guess today I've got
no idea that they're aged between 8 and
13 they think it's a pop of Russian run
by adults so to be a tough one it's
things like this today running this
freshman that confirm how talented these
six are I mean we're talking about five
star masterchef-worthy dishes that are
coming out of the kitchen from both of
the teams today so we're kids though
they're they happen they happen to be
kids but their culinary skill would
never suggest that what's the biggest
challenge of coaching and mentoring
these kids I'm I think finding that line
in terms of how far to push them there's
a snap already know I mean trouble push
them hard hard Gordon yeah we can also
listen the results are there right so
you know how many times we've been in
tears how many times are we've been down
on the knees and so it's that journey
and how do you bounce back and it's not
just the home cooks
chef Gordon pushes around I'll be dining
as one of the VIP guests so give me tips
like where should I be looking for is it
just taste that festival who said you a
VIP haha yeah we like you don't go
around calling yourself a VIP I'll be
down a few pegs going other people do
that for you because you
[Music]
you